The answer is we need to return two things.
We want the outputs to be the value of "url" and the value of "end_quote"
so we know both the "string" that was found—that's the target of
the link—as well as the value of "end_quote."
We can do that by just returning those two values.
We're going to have returning "url," followed by a comma,
followed by "end_quote."
That means that the two outputs from our procedure are the two
values of "url" and the value of "end_quote."
[Drawing smiley face.]
Congratulations! You've defined your first procedure.
This deserves a big smiley face.
Procedures are really important ideas in computer science.
We're going to find lots more procedures—both today
and through the rest of the course.
Almost everything we do "in terms of building programs" is
about building procedures.
Those are the main things that we use to break down problems
into things that we can solve.
We're going to have some more quizzes about procedures soon,
but first I want to give you an idea of how rich inputs and outputs can be
when we do computations.
We'll do that by looking at what happens when you
build a self-driving car.